[Music]
boy what's going on buddy my six trailer
just dropped Oh
better hurry dupes if we don't get this
up soon our subscribers gonna be pissed
[Music]
come on damn it start
[Music]
[Music]
you have to talk to her is this [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
tasty super bowl breakfast dude where
are you working is like right down the
street gun all right two bathroom doors
open
[Music]
yes we'll be able to the reactions all
right well this video is clear not gonna
be monetized as that song so go check
out our patreon legs are still sore from
that video that we shot guys um want to
thank Tony Gill trees II it's in the
gamer on Twitch this guy helped us out
with the entire shoot of that little
sketch that we guys just showed you how
to thank you
sorry we had to cut that one together
there's a lot of behind the scenes
bloopers we'll post on patreon for you
guys John fallout I love the Mission
Impossible series evidently I love Mia
Tommy Cruise this is fourth trailer
we're checking out today four shots in
as we're partying up here for the
Superbowl home has an official trailer
this is like the Super Bowl spot us it's
a big deal
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
surviving
[Applause]
whoa dad oh man
Hosie hell yeah oh my goodness
ankle
[Music]
came up I didn't realize that was a
helicopter it's it does and I also like
see the charm - mission of Mission
Possible to me has become sort of like
what if James Bond movies actually took
the time to remember where they've been
before and like I'm getting that vibe
from this especially like we're yeah
clearly keeping up with what's going on
we're letting this franchise age we're
letting you know the toll of all these
different missions you know come up to
Ethan Hunter whatever that's the thing
that I I've always thought was
interesting about this franchise I a lot
of people feel like ghost protocols when
this series got a reboot I kind of felt
like the reboot really occurred from mi3
mi - you know who am i three when it got
a lot more personal and you got to see
like Ethan hunts love life and he gets
married and that's just a really
personal grounded tale and in this one
it looks like Michelle Monaghan could
actually have some freaking scenes the
damn movie Ferguson and this is the
first time expending action anymore
is the first time a director has come
back from the prior installment to
direct the follow-up and this one it has
the vibe that I have expect Rissa from
Macquarie to provide where it will have
a serious tone but also have the cool
action and thrills and the intensity but
it seems like it's really going back to
what mi3 started which was a personal
tale about Ethan Hunt because a lot of
this seems to be about who's Ethan now
and how's Ethan become and it kind of
seems like it's dealing with Ethan aging
like there's even that part was climbing
the rock climbing thing that you know
pays tribute to like MIT this guys
getting older
his wife is coming back into the picture
people from it's the whole peak all the
people from the past seem to be coming
back Ving Rhames simon pegg Rebecca
Ferguson Michelle Monaghan it seems like
this is really going back to becoming a
personal tales that's the thing that I
felt was missing from Ghost Protocol and
Road nation granted I love this [ __ ] out
of those films and one thing I always
appreciate mi3 for
doing is having a real personal Ethan
Hunt tale and I feel like we're gonna
get the best of both worlds now we're
gonna get the big crazy-ass adventure
plus a personal tale of Ethan Hunt again
this is one of franchises that I do
still look forward to and I do still
feel the spectacle of because also I
mean it's part of their thing is the
stunts and authentically they fight that
you know I'm sure there are doubles for
some of it but the action looks really
intense I love that hook of what about
the mission like have you ever chosen
not to accept one like yeah I like
taking that motif and in twisting it I
hope they explore that more in this
movie and I like some of the character
actors they've got in here too yeah it
seems like they it seems that they're
taking some bold choices and doing some
real experimenting it looks like Henry
Cavill keeping the mustache it's gonna
pay off because he looks badass why you
kid
that's fight in that bathroom like it
looks like what I get from it from what
I heard on the Graham Norton Show and
from seeing the trailer looks like Tom
Cruise henry cavill are probably gonna
be enemies at first so they're hunting
each other at first and then eventually
they team up and start working together
yeah it seems like it's going down that
path but damn this is the coolest video
we've seen all throughout the Superbowl
so far yeah I'm sure there's other ones
to come out but this is easily the
coolest one man this is so Angela
Bassett as an addition to it yeah this
is a huge cast in this movie and and
there's snow there's no flash to James
Bond movies oh yeah totally realer but I
do think that even though there are
similarities there I feel like they've
built something kind of special out of
this franchise you know going it's
jumping out from the show and building
this up since the third one I feel like
they found a course and I really like
words I would not be surprised if this
is the best Mission Impossible we get I
might not be surprised if not it'll be
the most epic Mission Impossible yes so
it's gonna be one of the two are the
best or the most epic you know
all right well guys that was that was
cool guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified every time one of our
videos is up and please go check out our
patreon and plenty of the exclusive
posts over there a lot of rewards
everything goes to help keep this
channel alive love you guys maybe see
you later